on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored truss
and Biden Shake on the special
relationship because standing up to
Russia be their first priority
Putin threatens nuclear war and tells
the West this is not a bluff so will the
world blink or stare him down I'll take
on a Putin puppet in Moscow
and Dr Jordan Peterson one of the most
fascinating polemists on the planet
gives his shocking verdict on Ukraine's
war
a bit of Hitler and Stellar than
everyone really
there's more than a bit
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening from London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensor for days we've
been hearing that Vladimir Putin is on
the ropes Brave ukrainians backed by our
military muscle are taking back control
of thousands of square miles of their
country we're told that Putin's patched
up armies battered bloody and losing the
will to fight even his propagandists
known for spewing hate and lies on state
TV have dared to question their dictator
and tonight five British prisoners of
War detained in eastern Ukraine have
been released so Putin is clearly in
trouble there's nothing as dangerous as
a wounded bear and today he warned in
more chilling terms than ever but the
price range humiliation could be nuclear
war three hundred thousand reservists in
Russia will now be mobilized in the
biggest escalation since the invasion
make no mistake this is a dangerous
moment for the world it would be foolish
not to think very carefully about great
threats from either a bad man or a
Madman armed with more nukes than any
country in the world
when somebody bends over backwards to
keep telling you this is not a bluff
usually sounds an awful lot like a bluff
we can't live in a world where a guy
like Putin's saber rattling is nuclear
Arsenal can just get away with mass
murder By scaring us off
this might be Putin's last role of a
dice we don't know yet my view is now is
not the time to Blink it's the time to
double down in our support for the
ukrainians well by chance I sat down to
interview one of the most fascinating
thinkers on the planet today Dr Jordan
Peterson one of the most riveting and
emotional interviews I think I've ever
done we're going to air it all in full
on Tuesday but later in the show we're
going to share his grave and
extraordinary analysis of the situation
in Ukraine here's a taster
we can't win against Vladimir Putin
anyways because
you cannot win against someone you
cannot say no to
interesting stuff from Jordan Peterson
well let's start by going to New York
and I'll talk to the political leaders
of Kate McCann okay good to see a bit of
delay on on the on the sound tonight so
I'll just keep this the question simple
this trust has just met with President
Biden our new prime minister he
congratulated on her position he also
gave great uh I thought really lovely
tribute to our Queen and how much she in
the first lady enjoyed coming back to
London to be at the funeral and uh how
stunned they were by the the scale of
the uh warmth and feeling from the
British people towards her majesty this
trust returned uh the favor by saying to
him how grateful she was that he'd come
over and said that the queen was the
great Rock of this country it'd been a
very difficult two weeks they are of
course for two weeks and started her
Premiership so initial feelings okay
about body language between these two
people the special relationship where's
this all going do you think from the
these early encounters
so I think the special relationship is
so deeply embedded in the way the state
works here in America and in the UK that
the reality is the UK is one of the US's
best allies it's ready to go at the
touch of a button and what's happening
in Russia and Ukraine is you just set
out their peers makes that even more
important than ever the reality of the
security situation is that organizations
like the UN where we are today the G7
and others even though their financial
power as Nations is dwindling that
actually means that they need to now
work more closely together and they
recognize that they can see an enemy now
in Russia they can see the allies of
Russia China what might happen next in
Taiwan that is laid out very clearly
always but particularly here at the
United Nations and those conversations
on the margins and in the bilaterals
that you're seeing here are dominated by
talk of Ukraine what happens next yes
the hard-won battles to regain territory
but also how to rebuild Ukraine hundreds
of billions of dollars worth of damage
done whether that comes from Russia and
as you say there there are some
suggesting that now is the time for NATO
to be far braver to go further to arm
Ukraine in order to try and draw some
kind of line under what's happening here
so the body language between Liz truss
and President Biden relatively warm
those discussions at the top of meetings
on camera are always a bit awkward and
stilted everybody's reading out their
comments from that bit of paper trying
to get across to a domestic and an
international audience what they want to
achieve but the reality is the Bedrock
of that relationship is very stable very
solid and very important perhaps more
important than ever and that's what list
trusts the new prime minister wants to
build on in Her speech here tonight she
wants to say that more than ever the
economic power of big Nations like the
UK and the US needs to be drawn together
in the G7 and other organizations and
effectively used as skillfully as
defensive power against Russia now that
is a big ask it's going to be difficult
to do but there is a real grit in
determination here and some strong
language behind the scenes from
technomats too about Russia they won't
want to comment on camera about that
nuclear message from Putin they don't
want to give it credibility but it is at
the Forefront of everybody's Minds it
will not though make them waver in their
task right as you were talking there
we've got a clip just come in actually
of prime minister trust and President
Biden let's take a little look at this
you're our closest Ally in the world and
there's a lot we can do continue to do
together
and there's no issue that I could think
of a global consequence where the United
States United Kingdom are not working in
cooperation and that's why we want to
work more closely with the United States
especially on energy security
on our Economic Security but also in
reaching out to fellow democracies
around the world to make sure that
democracies prevail
I mean the one thing of course which is
a massive uh issue between him and
probably won't even be discussed is this
long promised trade deal between the UK
and the US which Biden has basically
said is a non-starter
yeah and I think that's why you saw Liz
trust the Prime Minister on the plane on
the way over here before the wheels had
even touched down in New York trying to
set expectations around a trade deal
because there's been some suggestion
here in America that the idea of a trade
deal is linked to the outcome of talks
over the Northern Ireland protocol
everyone essentially on all sides
digging in on that particular issue but
it does need to be solved and it needs
to be solved quickly because there needs
to be a government backup and running
power sharing an agreement something to
move politics forward so it's on the
Forefront of everybody's Minds here and
it's something that President Biden is
very keen to ensure that people
understand his commitment to the Good
Friday agreement and Liz truss too of
course has her position on that so those
talks are always very difficult in terms
of the domestic agenda but I think there
is a sense that both countries realize
and recognize that they do need to work
together here and trade is an issue of
course dominating the Northern Ireland
protocol talks but that at some point
we'll be dominating the relationship
between the UK and the US Liz Trust very
clearly on the plane saying that trade
deal is not going to come anytime soon
she did that so that the message here
from these talks couldn't be that deals
off the table until you sought the
Northern Ireland issue but the reality
is there are other issues with trade
between the UK and the US that also
complicate that deal attitudes to
tariffs for example complicated as those
negotiations always are which may well
slow that down but every time we have
asked on both the U.S side and the UK
side about trade deal the message is
very clear doesn't exist right now
nothing to talk about nothing to see
here it will exist one day but those
talks aren't even on the table yet okay
we can in New York thank you very much
indeed
or joining me to discuss a number of
things today former newspaper editor
Emily Sheffield conservative commentator
Esther kraku and Royal commentator and
former press secretary for our late
great Queen Dickie Arbiter welcome to
all of you thank you Dicky let me start
with you 12 years you were the press
secretary for her majesty this must have
been for you personally a very long and
sad and reflective 10 days it was long
it was sad it was reflected I didn't
quite get my head around it until I saw
the hearse leaving Balmoral Castle and
then again it hit me when the RF
regiments pallbearers took it off the
C-17 at northall airport there were
several moments when I nearly lost it I
was working for an Australian Channel
and um uh Ali
sort of grabbed my hand at once
yeah she she grabbed my hand because she
saw that something was a foot and I'm
very grateful to her for having done
that and that was when the coffin was
being lowered into the raw
um Crypt Hudson George's yeah it was an
incredibly poignant moment I mean that
was the moment really I felt a finality
the final moment where we would ever see
this queen in any form it was our final
moment to say goodbye and thank you your
majesty would she have been surprised by
the sheer scale of outpouring of love
and affection probably yes because every
time there was a jubilee she's still on
that balcony and the crowd stretched all
the way from Buckingham Palace back to
Trafalgar Square it was huge a million
people and she never quite believed it I
mean it happened on her golden jubilee
her diamond and her platinum and it was
something that she really didn't believe
I mean she almost echoed the words of
her grandfather George V the people love
me
and what came to mind while while you
were while you were talking is that
George V was called grandpa England and
I'd like to think that late Queen was
grandmother yes absolutely
um Emily a lot of issues coming out of
all this one is this concept being put
out that Charles may want a sort of
downsized coronation
if that is true what is your view of
that
well I don't know what it's downsizing
from but I imagine in other words
compare it to the Queens it won't be as
lavish or ostentatious as the Queens
when she was coronated not not her
funeral
um again I'm not entirely sure how
lavish it was but I think we've done it
was pretty lavish well I think somewhere
yeah you saw it I saw it I think
somewhere in the middle you know look as
old as I know you are
um well this interesting questions I
mean my gut feeling about this is if
you're going to have a monarchy do it
properly the great thing about the last
10 days was being able to show the world
that nobody has anything anywhere like
this so if you start downsizing
everything you kind of end up with a lot
of European monarchies when which it
becomes so downsized it becomes
pointless there are certain things in
the service you've got to have you got
to have the anointing you've got to have
the crowning the crowning might not be
the same as Lake Queens where the crown
was some Edwards Crown was placed on a
head it might be raised over over King
Charles's head and then placed on a
cushion a symbolic crowning and there'll
be two crownings because Camilla will be
crowned the queen console she will be
crowned the queen consort don't don't
start chipping away at tradition no I
don't think so yeah the only thing I
would warn may be is when the queen was
coronated this was a young woman a very
good looking young woman who had it the
shock of her father's death meant that
she was suddenly escalated to her role
as running the monarchy head of the
month
Charles is not going to have the same
glamor but isn't that even more reason
to make it look as glamorous as possible
well yes make it look glamorous but be
careful you don't over print okay let's
move to another another ongoing running
saw Esther we've talked about this many
times Megan and Harry can't be ignored
again their friend Gail King best
friends with Oprah Winfrey who of course
actually was the enabler for a lot of
this stuff with that we're actually
friends
well Gail and Oprah are great friends
yeah and the sussexes are neighbors of
Oprah so they sort of I think Megan's
hijacked them as friends as well
um here's the point though Gayle King
said on American television this morning
that she believes nothing's really been
resolved let's take a look
big families always go through drama
always go through turmoil it remains to
be seen are they going to be drawn
closer together or are they going to be
drawn apart I have no idea I have no
inside information on that but I will
tell you this it was good to see Harry
standing with his family
I mean it was but I'm not sure anything
got resolved yeah I think it's too early
to tell I think obviously everyone is
waiting with baited breath over Harry's
book which I really hope is not as sort
of bombastic as we fear it will be and
obviously you know Megan's podcast let's
hope she doesn't say anything more
egregious family I've read today it's
probably not true but it was an
interesting sort of take on it that
she's busy going through all the
podcasts and trying to remove anything
that attacks the monarchy because she
now knows how badly that would play the
problem they've got I think dick you in
this is that that's really their only
currency which is worth all the money
they don't have any other currency
they've already rubbished the royal
family and how you pull back from that I
really don't know you talk about
reconciliation there's a very wide Chasm
there isn't a bridge big enough to
bridge that castle and William I didn't
see William give Harry a single glance
the entire time they were seen in public
let alone Kate and and Megan it looked
at me like they were putting this show
on to to do it for their grandmother and
credit to them for being able to do that
but the enmity between them all is
incredibly real I mean it's not invented
by the media I do think that King
Charles
and the prince of Wales
have done the right thing which is to
put the Olive Branch out because they
need to be the grown-ups in the room
absolutely Megan and Harry like
bitching about the rock neutralize that
and they need to do it fast well they
need to shut up but they I mean they
just need to they left the country in
Duty for free I think they've done so go
and have your freedom and privacy and
shut up I hope I do hope they do
reconcile because I think there'll be a
positive thing for every everyone I
would advise Megan and Harry to find
some sort of expertise like I don't know
get a degree in neurobiology or
something because when you're only
around us
when you're only relevance stems from
being in that royal family with Megan's
case for two years you kind of want a
backup plan additionally Megan is going
to keep capitalizing on what she's been
capitalizing also yeah she's got a title
she's got a captive audience in the
United States I mean her the Sussex
Squad were tweeting in America but she
was the only one no no it's ridiculous
um let's turn to something happier
because I find there's a limited amount
of time we can give them before
everyone's spleen start to vent and the
pallbearers sticky I found it
unbelievably moving I've been reading
all about these ball bearings
um young men the finest of this first
Battalion Grenadier guards were chosen
for this Duty and clone in especially
from Iraq thrown in from Iraq in many
cases many of them had done uh War tools
and so on but they were chosen I can't
think of a more pressurized thing
to do actually other than actually
engaging in real war than what these
guys did was it you're right there more
urgent water please for Sheffield
um
I can't think of a bigger honor for
these guys or a bigger responsibility or
more stressed to have a billion people
around the world watching as you are
carrying a very four billion well for
well I think I probably was an
exaggeration but the the relatives a lot
and this is a very heavy coffin and it's
carrying the greatest Monarch in history
the pressure not to make any mistake
enormous they were completely
Thoughtless and the country I think
recognized that my question is should
the country go further and recognize
them with with honors absolutely
absolutely
um you know honors have been given to
people for lesser things this was a
great moment it was a great moment in
their lives it was a great moment in our
lives and it was a great moment for the
royal family oh we all agreed on this
yeah absolutely we're just discussing
back backstage weren't we whether it
went MBE Obe and youth or mbu I think
it's a start it's an MBA magazine they
can lift up eight MBS would be the least
we can give them and congratulations to
them and to their families it must have
been bursting with pride but imagine
being the parent of one of those kids
watching and thinking please don't let
anything go wrong you're talking about
the heavy the heaviness of the coffin an
American tweeted me and said what are
they making so much fun they're only
carrying a box I tweeted back and said
it's lead lined yeah now go away oh
exactly yeah you get idiots you should
stay off Twitter dick you're far too
venerable for that kind of behavior I
get annoyed it's great to see I wanted
to catch up with you because I'm sure
you've been through a lot of emotions in
the last couple of weeks and um it was a
historic moment I think the country did
the queen proud the country did the
queen proud the the people were
magnificent there was no angst in the
queue not a few celebrities allegedly
jumping the queue but they were they
were all very friendly they were all
very relaxed when somebody had to go out
of the queue perhaps to go to the new or
be interviewed on television they got
their place back in the queue there was
no squeezing you weren't impressed by
the cue jumpers no not particularly I
thought David Beckham was brilliant
queuing up for 14 hours yeah we won't
talk about the others uh do you watch
the the chase on TV the chase the quiz
show no should I have it well you're
about to be replaced by one of the
Chasers
in that seat
[Laughter]
for giving you that watch it you won't
take it as a personal insult uh great to
see you Dickie you too thanks for catch
up soon you too stay with me we're going
to bring in and hegerty of course from
the chase one of the great Chasers to
replace the Irreplaceable Dickies good
to see you still had to fight more on my
exclusive interview with controversial
clinical psychologist Jordan Peterson
meaning why he thinks is a dangerous
dictator in all of us
there's a bit of Hitler and Stellar than
everyone really
there's more than a bit
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook downstairs
Emily Sheffield Esther crack is still
here plus very exciting this I've been
joined by Anne Hagerty the quizzer
extraordinaire and intellectual
Powerhouse a TV quiz show The Chase
nice to be here are you as are you as
mean and absolutely Sinister and
intimidating in real life I'm horrible
what is lovely to see you thank you a
very unexpected little bonus uh I'm
talking about bonuses I want to start
with Bankers bonuses I don't know why
Liz truss's first priority for this
country appears to be letting bankers
get richer well because let's say a bank
makes a certain amount of profit if it
hangs on to that profit then it has to
pay corporation tax on it at what 19
If instead it gives some of that profit
to its employees then they have to pay
income tax on it on what is it 45 at 45
so more money goes into the treasury But
ultimately when you have food banks
exploding when you have food prices
Energy prices crippling families the
Optics are saying actually one of the
first things we're going to do is let
bankers get richer I think it's really
it might be something that works
it's bad politics I I quite agree some
people aren't going to like the Optics
of it but I think that we can tolerate a
lot of red-faced young men throwing
bread rolls at each other in the IV if
it actually means that more money goes
into the treasury they actually make
less money because the logic is if
because Bankers actual salaries have
gone up because they've kept the bonuses
so it's actually made them less um less
risk-averse which they should be so if
you actually you know remove the cap the
base salary goes down and it makes them
actually behave but the problem we have
with the financial crash before was that
the bonuses were getting so
stratospherically big they all began
behaving recklessly but in the industry
was heavily regulated so now there are
more regulations to actually police that
sort of thing they just don't change
their spots I mean I'm nothing against
Bankers personally but give them a load
of cash
Emily Am I Wrong well I think that it's
this hasn't been much around the
regulation so as you say back to the
financial crash mostly in America
subprime they were getting huge bonuses
for not delivering anything right so we
do need to keep the I think it's right
they should be allowed to be paid
whatever bonus the bank thinks right but
make sure there's some regulation
they're getting the bonus for delivering
exactly and I to your point yes it's the
politics of Envy if you say everyone
should be paid a certain amount and that
money does go out it goes into
restaurants in London for instance we're
having absolutely terrible time at the
moment but to your point about the
politics I don't think she meant this to
be leaked out right I think there's a
lot of frustration actually the Sunday
Times reported on that because of course
that's not the first thing you want to
come out
now especially when you're talking that
they don't want to do a windfall she
doesn't want to do a win well again why
would you also brief that you're not
going to tax the energy companies
because they're the first people I'd be
putting a windfall tax on so if it look
it's a bold strategy if it works if it
goes wrong but you look back and say
well why would you announce those two
things well she aged she didn't it was a
leak apparently she was very cross about
the bank well that in itself made me
disingenuously no and then in itself
if one of her own team leaked it you've
got to think can you trust your own team
or are they boris's people and is there
actually foreign
Phil and this extraordinary developing
Scandal that these two very popular
morning television presenters
jumped the queue as people see it uh by
using a media pass to bypass having to
queue up with the public what do you
think of this well the point as I have
made exhaustively on Twitter is that
everything on Twitter is exhausting yes
I've been muting a lot of people there
will be people shouting at me right now
that I can't hear
um but um yes as I understand it they
were heading down the side of
Westminster Hall to go to the Press area
because they had media accreditation
along with hundreds of other people most
of them people we happen not in fact
recognize so they will I mean I know
they would they were journalists there
was a journalist from Yorkshire yeah I
know exactly Susanna Reid who's my my
former TV wife she queued with her mum
for you know 10 hours whatever it was
she wanted to David working I know but
my I don't think any of the journalists
actually should have skipped the main
queue personally I don't think anyone
should have done apart from world
leaders were literally you know they've
only got an hour I don't think that MPS
and members of the House of Lords should
be well I agree no I agreement
they were simply walking down the hall
to do it but having said that I also
don't think that the pylon has been fair
and I don't think they should be fired
as some people seem to want to do this
petition is up to 35 000 people at the
front page of every paper like it's the
biggest Scandal of all time it's like
look they made in my opinion a
misjudgment as every journalist did that
did this because the public were doing
their Duty and it looked like the
journalists worked so I think that was
the era of judgment but the reaction has
been absurd but also we've just had the
most thing we've all been talking I was
here only what two nights ago and
talking about the unity of the the
funeral yeah and what this is the
outcome seriously well Britain is
great if you ever tried to jump in the
Cure Alton tires it doesn't it doesn't
go well this is the takeaway you know
it's a few days later looking past the
queue well there is a benefit nothing to
do there is a benefit from the whole
thing London dungeon has announced that
if you go down to London dungeon and use
the uh password Holly and Phil you get
fast track team
a lot of companies trading on this uh
genius I want to talk to Esther if I may
about uh Peter the um the Animal Rights
group who've announced uh that
apparently
um meat eaters should be banned from
having sex uh and their explanation is
that devouring sausages and schnitzel
this is the German Peter analysis is a
symptom of toxic masculinity killing the
planet they called on women to go on sex
strike to save the world and they cited
research saying that men cause 41 more
greenhouse gas emissions than women
because they consume more meat I would
Hazard a guess that the people having
the best sex are probably people that do
eat meat so
um they should probably have a sex
therapist in there too I mean my issue
with this as a meat eater and I will
continue being a meat eater is that by
this logic Emily I would have to end up
having sex only with hungry vegans and I
can't imagine learning words in the
world than that so this is like and
we're heading into the Dante's Inferno I
don't understand the sex connection why
Wow I do think we all should it's
because vegans are joyless and humorless
and they want to suck all the pleasure
out of life that's why I I'm struck by
the uh the spokesman who was saying you
know that all these men that they're
grilling sausages on the grill and and
if you bring a cool jet everyone's very
cross he's obsessed with
and also I'm obsessed with sausages and
here's my message to Peter if you're
watching which is I'm going to carry on
having my bangers thank you very much in
every sense so
oh
lovely
sausage anybody
I shouldn't be caught on TV wanted to
talk to my parents thank you for coming
in and what a delight a delight to have
you uh that's enough on my panel for
tonight unfortunately we're gonna move
on to much more serious matters which is
Ukraine war and Vladimir Putin as the
Russian dictator ramps up threats of
nuclear war Dr Jordan Peterson tells me
exclusively why the Russian president
isn't one to Bluff
if necessary they'll use a tactical
Battlefield weapon even if it starts
world war three it won't probably why
because we wouldn't respond
foreign
foreign
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to peers organization
technical psychologist Dr Jordan
Peterson is one of the world's most
fascinating and controversial
intellectuals his books sell by the
boatload his talks back theaters across
the globe Millions watch him online when
he speaks people listen I interviewed
him early today at length and we'll add
most of that conversation next week but
on the day that Putin threatened nuclear
war on the west I had to ask Jordan
Peterson but his analysis on the war in
Ukraine his response was as Grave as it
was startling that's the world's most
famous psychologist and began by asking
for his view on Vladimir Putin as a man
well he's a lot more like everybody else
than anyone thinks you know the notion
that he's Hitler or Stella and that's
just foolish I don't see any evidence
for that at all I mean first of all
Hitler and stellen were very singular
types and there's a bit of Hitler and
stellen and everyone so you know there's
some truth in that maybe there's more in
the typical Russian language really
there's more than a bit really
oh absolutely yeah well why would have
not seism spread the way it did you know
people think well that's all top down
it's not top down
there's there's a part of people that
are all these people who informed on
Kate Burleson well didn't go but didn't
gobble say that the way to get vast
numbers of people to go on with what you
want to do is to terrify them yeah well
that you can build a group of Terror
over them oh yeah but in a way that's
what Putin's now doing with the Russian
people where he's going back now into a
position of they're all trying to get us
they want to attack us they want to take
us over he's terrifying his people to
Rally support for what at the moment is
a conflict he has started which is not
going the way he assumed well the most
um what would you say the wisest
commentators on totalitarian States like
like social Nets
and and many psychological commentators
young was a good example of that made a
very straightforward case that you can't
have a totalitarian state unless every
single person is willing to lie about
everything all the time and you can
think about that as top down because the
leaders lie too and they also enforce
punishments if you don't lie but then
you can also think about it
the the totalitarian spirit is
replicated at every level of the society
and so in a truly totalitarian state
husbands lie to their wives and parents
lie to their children and the
totalitarian state is actually the grip
of the lie and so and and people will
certainly go along with that I mean I
mean we're seeing that emerge here with
Castle culture it's like lie yes or else
yes like yeah well and the Russian
people will be bombarded all the time
with State media propaganda and we'll be
buying into a little while Putin is
saying yeah
how does this war end do you think
you're going to find out this winter
well I I know what I would do in his
shoes
I'd wait till the first cold snap and
shut off the tops right well because I
was going to do this he's got the
control over there
of course he's going to do this he's
already warned the West with his
insistence that maintenance problems
were necessary and the pipelines do you
think he will use a nuclear weapon if
necessary he'll use a tactical
Battlefield weapon even if it starts
world war three it won't probably why
because we wouldn't respond
what's in it for us
if you let him do it and get away with
it where does that end then you are into
it well look there's a lot you can get
yourself in this situation no problem
where there's no good outcome we're
trying to do that right now on every
front we can possibly imagine we can
easily get ourselves in a situation
where it's hell this way and hell that
way that we're that's highly probable we
should the ukrainians give the Russians
anything when I was over there recently
interviewing president zielinski what I
was struck by was everybody I met in
Keys the capital city were utterly
Resolute don't give them an inch of our
land yeah well I don't I can't speak to
that because I don't know what the
preconditions for peace might be but I
do know that naive Notions that the
Russians are going to lose somehow or
that we're going to win
I I don't I just don't understand I
don't understand that well what do you
mean we're going to win what are we
going to win here exactly well I guess a
victory would be that the Russians
retreated from Ukraine
with with Ukrainian ruins
right well that's a hell of a victory
like I think Putin could manage that
because I think he could tell his people
and I think they might buy it it's like
we accomplished our objective we
devastated Ukraine and we kept it out of
the hands of the West and that's not
great
it's not what we'd hoped for but it's
better than the alternative and I think
they would buy that and I think when
Putin went into Ukraine I thought well I
thought a bunch of things which I I made
a YouTube video about that people
criticized like Matt I thought okay well
what's happening here oh I see
his his end game for failure is that
that Ukraine is left in the smoking room
oh that's a victory
so then he can lose with impunity right
so how can we win
we can't win against Vladimir Putin
anyways because
you cannot win against someone you
cannot say no to
period
and we can't say no to Putin because we
sold our soul for his oil and gas and we
did that to elevate our moral stature in
relationship to saving the planet and so
here we are yeah facing a very dire
winter
hoisted on the patard of our own
foolishness and moral presumption we're
saving the planet
we'll see I don't think so
it doesn't look like it to me and this
is this is the most catastrophic issue
here assuming that we're facing an
environmental crisis of planetary
proportions which is not something I buy
by the way assuming we are well then I
would imagine that you would put in
place measures that would ameliorate
that problem
instead of exacerbating it but all the
measures you're putting in place are
actually making the environmental
problem worse so how is that even
vaguely acceptable and I look at that
and I think oh I see it's just like
George Orwell said about middle class
socialists 50 years ago it's not that
you love the planet it's that you hate
Humanity
so well have at her boys and girls and
we'll see what happens this winter and
it's very terrifying to me I especially
here you know because your energy prices
have gone way out of control and that's
going to hurt a lot of poor people and
and certainly around the world as well
the World Bank already estimated that we
put 350 million people into what they
call a food insecurity 350 million
that's three times as many as the
Communists managed to kill maybe we can
manage that in the winter but the planet
has too many people on it anyway so you
know that's just poor people
fascinating take from Jordan Peterson
we'll be showing my full interview with
this extremely fascinating and
compelling intellectual uh next week uh
he's certainly a guy against everyone
talking and I really recommend you watch
it uh there were several moments which
to me by surprise one was when he got
very emotional my stage of the interview
another when I asked him if he could
analyze me
and to say
you're a net force for good if you want
to be
having met me now for an hour what would
your initial clinical diagnosis be
well you'll get that answer next week
I'll keep you on tender hooks but it's
quite fascinating hard to say well
Jordan Peterson says the West can't beat
Vladimir Putin is he right and are we
facing potential nuclear war I'll be
getting reaction to that the former U.S
National Security Council official
Robert Spaulding and best-selling author
Douglas Murray and former advisor to
President Putin Sergey Mark that's next
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
well before the break we heard
controversial clinical psychologist
Jordan Peterson tell me this about
Putin's nuclear war he said that
basically we can't win we can't beat the
guy because we're too reliant on him for
energy we'll form a White House National
Security Council official Brigadier
General Robert Spaulding best-selling
author Douglas Murray and former adviser
to President Putin Sergey Markov all
join me now let me start with you if I
may uh Brigadier General Spaulding what
did you make of Jordan Peterson saying
that he believes we're too beholden to
Vladimir Putin on energy for us to get
any win here
well I I do think that he has a point in
that Putin is not really going to be
beaten in this and I think it has really
less to do with energy and really more
to do with what we're willing to risk in
order to create a military Victory here
and I think you know there's a good
predicate for what's happening in
Ukraine and that is the Korean War so we
went back and forth in the Korean war
with an adversary that didn't have
nuclear weapons in China at the time and
so I think we need to think very clearly
with regard to what are our aspirations
and understand that this is a cold word
that will last for probably decades and
these this is just the opening Salvo
okay let me go to Sergey Markov in
Moscow an advisor to Vladimir Putin a
former member of the Russian State
Doomer thank you for joining me uh Mr
Markov you're on the airwaves this
morning in Britain uh saying that
Putin's made it clear he'll be ready to
use his nuclear Arsenal against Western
countries including against Great
Britain and that it would all be our
fault because we've been the aggressors
is is that your position
uh of course uh and of course
nuclear war is every normal
psychologically person and believe me
very normal psychologically and but same
time we can see this war in
Ukraine it's a lot of psychology and
irrationality it's more personal war of
Joe Biden against
uh I can explain why was it Joe Biden
that invaded Ukraine I must have I must
have missed that because I could I mean
I could have been sure that in February
Vladimir Putin
let me ask you a question let me ask you
a question mark obvious try and keep it
reasonable
as far as I'm aware it was Vladimir
Putin that illegally invaded a sovereign
Democratic country Ukraine in February
not often Joe Biden no no no you must
you lost the point
um uh Russia didn't invade Ukraine but
Russia sent troops to liberate Ukraine
from occupation
which had been imposed by United States
to the Ukrainian people
Russia did invade Ukraine that's just an
undeniable fact Russia invaded Ukraine
it is discussions
foreign
stop shouting
Ukrainian people voted overwhelmingly
for democracy they continue to support
democracy they don't want to be part of
the old Soviet Union well they did no
it's just a it's a demonstrable fact no
no uh in Ukraine all elections
2015 can be pacified right it was
stirror now thousands of thousands of
people is a political prisoner and I'm
particular
the truth is
yeah your friends
we can't keep talking over each other Mr
Marco but let me say this to you
Vladimir Putin is clearly losing this
war or he wouldn't now be mobilizing 300
000 reservists he wouldn't have been
losing territory that he gained the
Russians are losing the war and that is
why Vladimir Putin is now taking these
Extreme Measures
no
what happened let me put on board to
your uh uh uh to know if Joe Biden and
your Prime Ministers almost crazy I
think Buddy Johnson a distress uh uh
will continue their time before against
Russia Israel could lead to the
irrational scenario where nobody will
control an attractor will have nuclear
war another Russians
the constant threats from Russia about
nuclear weapons are frankly pathetic
absolutely pathetic it's behaving like a
bully in the school playground you know
Mr Markov I've got to leave it there
thank you very much for joining me let's
go to Douglas Murray in New York Douglas
um
obviously a ridiculous conversation in
many ways but what is your take on the
reality do you think no Mr Markov we're
done I'm so sorry
um Douglas tell me about the the
situation from your perspective here
we've only got a few minutes left but
where are we with this this supposed
conflict but it was obviously a war
well obviously a Russia invaded Ukraine
earlier this year and what we've just
heard is very typical Kremlin propaganda
which uh some people believe and they've
managed to persuade uh much of the
Russian public to believe and others
just are doing this cynically for
cynical political reasons but the the
interesting thing of course is that the
course of this war so far is that it has
been undeniably a huge failure for
Vladimir Putin his forces did not manage
to get to Kiev uh as they wanted to in
the initial days uh zielinski and the
Ukrainian government did not flee it
turned out that Russia's Supply chains
were totally inadequate it turned out
the billions of dollars they'd paid for
uh in a military Tech in a tech tech
system that was meant to allow generals
and others to speak on on secure lines
was surprise surprise mainly money that
had gone in corruption and kickbacks
like everything else in Putin's wife and
didn't work and so Russia has been
losing senior generals it's now of
course not winning of course it's not
winning if you you have to call that 300
000 reservists
um most of whom are going to be
completely untrained then of course
you're not winning the interesting
question though is this from the point
of view of the West how long can this
conflict be drawn out it seems to me of
course that the the dangerous thing my
friend Jordan Peterson mentioned this
earlier they're the dangerous thing is
this winter Vladimir Putin will be
hoping to Hive off at least one member
of the Western Alliance as the energy
problem gets worse into the winter but
this conflict's clearly going to go into
next year now here's the problem if I
can say someone we should all be
thinking about his Vladimir Putin's
going to in some sense lose this war but
not completely and that's not entirely a
bad thing because the most dangerous
scenario and I think we've just had one
of his sort of puppet blowhards that
we've just heard from the most dangerous
scenario is undoubtedly Vladimir Putin
losing humiliatingly because a
humiliated Putin is I think the most
dangerous Computing and and that's why I
think for all of our hopes that you know
Russia can be completely thrown out of
Ukraine and this illegal War can be
reversed to the status quo anti all of
our hopes of that the reality is that at
some point there's going to have to be
some kind of discussion which allows
Putin basically to retreat as
magnanimously as possible
you know it's interesting I mean this is
what Jordan was saying I don't disagree
with a sort of intellectual analysis of
this but just going back to the general
sporting for a moment that does mean in
the end that Ukraine would have to
surrender some more territory and when I
was over there recently that was the
last thing they wanted to do but is that
inevitable
well I think it's the same thing as I
said that happened during the Korean War
I don't think the South Koreans are you
know particularly happy about the
demilitarized zone but it's something
that we're going to have to find a way
to coexist and let this long-term
competition between authoritarianism and
democracies play out one of the problems
that I think that we have to come to
grips with is that we are pouring
enormous sums into China who is in turn
pouring enormous sums into Russia that's
not going to help us long term it's not
also not going to help us that they that
China owns a supply chain which is not
something that we had during the first
Cold War so we've got a lot of com
competing to do and a lot of work to do
and you know it's not just going to
happen in Ukraine General thank you very
much indeed Douglas Murray thank you
very much indeed this will keep you guys
a huge developing story again in Ukraine
but that's it for me tonight whatever up
to Keep It Uncensored good night
what was my biggest career moment after
spending about 25 years of Fleet Street
there's loads of stories I could tell
you but actually I think I did an
overnight show for Tool radio in the
early days the night of the brexit
referendum and that was actually quite a
milestone because of course we started
off thinking
um that remain had won and at half past
two quarter three after Nigel farage had
already said he'd lost it turned out he
hadn't lost but it turned out we were
leaving the European Union so that was
quite a shocking
this is talk TV news
good evening I'm Nadira Tudor five
British prisoners of War have been
released from Russia and are on their
way back to the UK two of them Aiden
Aslan and Sean Pinner had been sentenced
to death they were photographed arriving
at Riyadh airport both were accused of
being mercenaries Saudi Arabia helped
negotiate the deal to free the group
which included 10 prisoners of war in
total meanwhile Russians have been
holding protests in the country's
biggest cities tonight following a
decision by Vladimir Putin to call up
300 000 reservists to fight in the war
in Ukraine dozens have been arrested and
energy bills for businesses in the UK
will be cut by around half their
expected level this winter the
government will impose a price cap for
six months from the 1st of October
hospitals schools and Charities will
also get some help that's all for now
we'll have more after the talk
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign